[Música]
una vez ya me acuerdo y me empieza a
reír que nos encontramos con unos amigos
en un bar y como suele pasar todas las
mesas ocupadas
la recepcionista amablemente no tomo la
reserva y decidimos esperar una especie
de cómodos sillones los minutos
empezaron a correr y nuestros nombres no
se pronunciaban pero lo peor de todo es
que seguía ingresando gente al bar y esa
gente si le daban mesas antes que a
nosotros
disculpad está ingresando gente al bar y
le están dando mesa antes que a nosotros
le dije la recepcionista ella me explica
que las mesas las iban entregando en
base a la cantidad de gente que
ingresaba en cada mesa sin importar
quién estaba antes o después
no me quedé conforme con su respuesta y
para sorpresa de mí mismo en ese momento
mi cerebro tuvo como una especie de
reacción pero hacia acá en el hemisferio
derecho la parte que controla la
imaginación y el pensamiento artístico
sabe quién soy yo le pregunté ella
agarra me miró los sueños bien fruncidos
y me dice
no
era los días previos para las elecciones
para concejal en la ciudad de rosario
a quién vas a votar este domingo para
concejal le pregunté ella agarra y
sorprendía con mi pregunta las cejas
bien levantadas así me dice
pozos candidatos por algún partido ese
pie hizo que rápidamente mi cerebro acá
en el hemisferio izquierdo se pusiera en
funcionamiento tan rápido como el
correcaminos escapando del coyote
esta parte de nuestro cerebro que
desarrolla el habla me permitió con un
lenguaje acorde a lo que necesitaba la
situación decirle a qué partido
pertenecía como figura mi nombre en la
lista quiénes eran los que integraban el
resto del equipo quienes trabajaban con
nosotros y demás
mis ojos y el de mis amigos iban de un
lado a otro pero no de asustados por lo
que había pasado sino de sorprendidos
muchos mozos iban y venían con mesas y
sillas era como si el depósito se
estuviera prendiendo fuego estaban
sacando todo ahí
o sea al cabo de unos tres minutos
teníamos unas mesas armadas en el salón
principal
el haber estudiado teatro me pudo haber
dado algunas herramientas que puede
utilizar para ser creíble mi relato pero
el secreto en esta anécdota es que la
recepcionista nunca pudo ver las
imperfecciones que tenía mi historia
por un lado pudo haber sentido el deseo
de creerme porque estaba frente a una
persona conocida
famosa o de poder pero por el otro lado
pudo haber sentido
si quedaba en ridículo en desconfiar de
este no famoso no conocido y no poderoso
todos nosotros tanto la recepcionista
como todos nosotros estamos día tras día
expuesto a situaciones noticias
informaciones que vemos escuchamos y
hasta en las que participamos mucha
información ingresa a nosotros y es ahí
donde la codifica moss con algún
propósito
por un lado están aquellas personas que
creen
pero por el otro están los escépticos
hola
no somos ningunas personas con poderes
especiales no tenemos ningún tipo de
enfermedad la única diferencia con el
resto es que nuestro cerebro está
siempre activo y hace que nuestros
sentidos estén en alerta donde la duda
no pasa a ser algo malo en nuestras
vidas sino una herramienta para ver
diferente las cosas
por ejemplo
quien no fue tentado alguna vez por la
foto de una hamburguesa sabrosa y al
momento de comprar la hamburguesa se
quedaron con ganas de comer la foto por
encima de la hamburguesa
de paso no
llega el momento de vacaciones hay que
lugar hay que decidir el lugar donde nos
vamos a hospedar y siempre hay algo que
decidimos porque vemos o escuchamos algo
el año pasado fuimos con unos amigos a
centroamérica y mi amigo el tigre dice
que reserva un hotel porque se había
convencido de que la pileta tenía muchas
reposeras con vistas al mar
a quien no le gusta estar en sus
vacaciones en una reposera viendo el mar
en la pileta lo que pasa que muchas
veces decidimos por esto
y lo que nos termina pasando es esto
otro
y muchos de nosotros seguramente hemos
participado pero las cadenas de whatsapp
en su momento cuando decían que el
servicio se iba a dejar de ser gratuito
y demás y nos pedían que enviemos dicho
mensaje se acuerdan de estos mensajes
hay que mandar el mensaje sino nuestros
teléfonos no van a tener más whatsapp
bueno si alguno de ustedes les llegó
este mensaje quiere decir que la persona
que se los envió creyó previamente en
estas palabras
pero cuando estamos escuchando la radio
o viendo la televisión que la voz de la
locutora nos envuelve en hoteles
transporta a otra dimensión escuchen
este audio
nuestras convicciones más arraigadas más
indubitables son las más sospechosas
ellas constituyen nuestro límite
nuestros confines nuestra prisión
josé ortega y gasset estás presenciando
el té de c's funes 2018
se imaginan cómo es
morocha rubia alta un poco mas petista
y realizamos muchas veces a una persona
sin conocerla
ella es lydia cabrera locutora nacional
que ha hecho muchísimas publicidades en
radio y en televisión a la que aprovecho
y le mando un gran saludo desde acá por
haberse copado en participar en esta
charla
a que con el sonido de su voz no se la
imaginaron así ahí ya se ríen por allá
ya hay otras caras medias raras como ven
a través de todos nuestros sentidos
podemos experimentar situaciones que
nuestro cerebro juega con la intuición
pero está comprobado que puede fallar
rené descarte fue quien instauró la duda
metódica
esta persona dijo que dudar la duda
meteórica se trata de dudar de los
conocimientos que no fueran evidentes él
decía que si los sentidos nos engañan
una vez lo pueden hacer siempre
cage sueños que son tan reales que no
podemos distinguirlo de nuestra vigilia
y por último habla de la razón ya que al
fallar en resolver un problema este
hecho nos está indicando que podemos
volver a fallar
cuando estudiaba en la facultad de
arquitectura en una clase de historia me
llamó mucho la atención en el período
gótico
como el arte influenciado por el fervor
religioso
tenía el fin de atraer más fieles
me preguntaba por qué nadie en la edad
media se había puesto a dudar de que
dios o los ángeles no eran esas
destellos de luces que entran por las
grandes catedrales góticas
este
por estos ventanales gigantescos porque
todos creían en las palabras de las
nuevas órdenes monásticas nadie se puso
a dudar de que era un simple destello de
luz que al atravesar el vidrio si nos da
una imagen divina pero no era más que
una luz no era ningún ser especial que
venía por nosotros
vamos a la historia
los voy a llevar a fines de los años
vayan pensando en un personaje histórico
cristobal colon se paró frente a los
reyes y si bien él estaba seguro de lo
que él quería
los reyes no lo estaban tanto la reina
isabel de castilla tenía muchas dudas
con su viaje con destino a las indias
las cortes españolas lo oyen rechazo en
tres oportunidades pero colom nunca dudó
que navegando hacia el oeste iba a
llegar a destino
su discurso fue tan persuasivo que los
reyes le aprobaron su petición y éste
consiguió su aventura
pero que hubiese pasado
si este mismo discurso
lo hubiese dicho el bufón del castillo
ustedes consideran que los reyes
hubieran actuado de la misma manera que
actuaron con colom seguramente no es más
ese bufón
hubiese terminado en un calabozo
con esto lo que les quiero mostrar es
que es tan importante saber que se dice
como también quién es la persona que no
lo está diciendo de dónde proviene lo
que se dice y cuál es la imagen que la
persona no está entregando al momento de
decirlo
a lo largo de los años de la humanidad
muchas personas no dudaron de sus
conocimientos a pesar de ser perseguidos
por sus ideas
y así todo lograron hacerlas públicas
y gracias a que lo lograron porque
fueron las bases de muchos conocimientos
que la ciencia corroboró años
posteriores
galileo galilei descubrió que la tierra
giraba alrededor del sol
instauró la ley de gravitación universal
charles darwin revolucionado todo con su
teoría de la evolución de las especies
de las especies
y así podría seguir nombrando a millones
de personas que gracias a avión no
dudaron de sus conocimientos a pesar de
ir en contra de los pensamientos
sociales
parado acá arriba
viéndolos a ustedes
me preguntó
no habrá un posible galileo galilei
isaac newton
o por qué no
un charles darwin
les hago una pregunta
qué pasa cuando dudamos de nosotros
mismos alguien sabe
todos nosotros tenemos una serie de
creencias que hemos ido incorporando y
las aceptamos como son así tal cual
varias
han llegado a nosotros tal vez de forma
casual oa veces por la enseñanza que
hemos recibido
pero nunca nunca nunca no le hemos
puesto a revisar
estas creencias han formado el mundo en
que nos movemos estas creencias nos han
formado como somos nosotros
es muy importante que revisemos estas
creencias para ver si son útiles
correctas o verdaderas
muchas veces nos privamos de nuevas
experiencias por desconfiar de nuestras
propias capacidades
vieron que les toca rendir un examen y
qué pasa
empezamos a dudar
si presentarnos o no presentarnos si
estudiamos lo suficiente o no estudiamos
lo suficiente
estamos en el trabajo y las cosas nos
están saliendo bien es momento de pedir
un aumento del sueldo
la duda nuevamente
si hablamos con nuestro jefe o no
hablamos si mejor lo dejamos para otro
momento
estás en una relación de pareja y las
cosas no están bien tienes que decirles
lo que te pasa
y otra vez la duda
tienes miedo de decírselo no sabes si se
va a enojar cómo se lo vas a decir
a diario estamos tomando decisiones todo
el tiempo a veces de forma imperceptible
pero hay personas que les resulta una
tarea muy difícil desde que se levantan
hasta que se acuestan están dudando
ninguno de nosotros sabe en futurología
el resultado de nuestras acciones pero
de algo estoy seguro
aquellas personas que no corren ningún
ningún riesgo por más pequeño que sea
estoy seguro que no podrán recorrer
nuevos caminos
además de dedicarme a la arquitectura
hace unos años comenzó a trabajar en los
medios de comunicación más precisamente
en la radio una pasión que descubrí
gracias a que no dude en si estaba
capacitado o no para poderlo hacerlo
los medios de comunicación son los
encargados de la manipulación de las
noticias
los medios digitales en los que nos
movemos hoy en día de un artículo a otro
hacen que con el simple hecho de apretar
un botón nos llegue información
verdadera que se mezcla con información
falsa
bien aunque vamos tan rápido por la vida
hoy en día que hasta nuestro informamos
rápido
vemos una noticia y solamente con el
título tratamos de entender de qué se
trata
es muy larga entonces vamos
seleccionando párrafos a ver si
entendemos lo que nos puede decir la
nota
y esta vez si vemos la foto y un par de
líneas
pero eso eso no está bien
la radio y la televisión utilizan
periodistas y comunicadores para
hacernos llegar la noticia correcta
pero quitando y correcta es esa noticia
cuando sabemos que hay intereses por
captar más gente prendió al dial o
frente a la pantalla
con esto se aumenta el rating y con
mayor rating vienen mayores beneficios
económicos
cuidado
toda información que nosotros
manipulamos puede influir en la vida de
los demás ya sea con mensajes erróneos o
informaciones a medias lo que hace que
pienses en una cosa que verdaderamente
no lo es
yo sé que les estoy dejando una tarea
muy difícil y que estás desalentadoras
palabras hace que de verdad nos
planteemos si lo que llega a nuestras
manos es verídico o no pero somos
nosotros los consumidores que tenemos la
tarea de diferenciar entre una
información verdadera y una información
falsa es por eso que los quiero ver y
que vean a la duda como una herramienta
de vida
cuando se enfrenten ante una duda no se
espanten
la bienvenida
de hecho no tengo ninguna duda que van a
poderlo hacer muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]